i
[Música]
hola muy venidos a una nueva emisión de
la entrevista de france 24 en esta
oportunidad nos acompaña andrea gracia
ella es periodista tiene discapacidad
visual y es además integrante de red y
la red por los derechos de las personas
con discapacidad con ella vamos a
abordar un tema que suele estar rodeado
de tabúes y hasta de prejuicios hablamos
de la sexualidad y el goce de las
personas con discapacidad
andrea gracias muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la revista de france 24
hola santiago muy buenas tardes no al
contrario muchas gracias a ustedes por
el espacio no gracias a vos por favor
andrea habitualmente aunque por lo
general sin ningún fundamento por
supuesto muchas personas consideran que
las personas con discapacidad no pueden
vivir plenamente su sexualidad hay una
suerte de negación de su sexualidad y
también de su goce y de ser así aquí lo
atribuí sandrea
y por lo general lo que se suele pensar
es que las personas con discapacidad y
por lo general la mujer
con discapacidad
somos
para una gran cantidad de personas como
una suerte de líneas eternas
y más allá de lo que tiene que ver con
la sexualidad en sí hay algo más
profundo más amplio que tiene que ver
con el derecho a la autonomía con la
posibilidad de tomar decisiones con
autonomía se suele pensar que
las mujeres por el hecho de tener una
discapacidad no podemos
tomar decisiones no podemos
ser no podemos comprender lo que implica
tomar una decisión
no podemos tener autonomía para un
montón de cosas por ejemplo para incluso
para tener un empleo para
para
educarnos para ejercer determinadas
responsabilidades y además para poder
decidir sobre nuestra sexualidad y
ejercer la creo que tiene que ver sobre
todo con un prejuicio muy grande que
tiene que ver con
esto con entender que las mujeres con
discapacidad en
somos ante todo mujeres somos personas
que podemos tener una condición de
discapacidad y que podemos bueno en todo
caso necesitar algún tipo de
a 8 para acceder a la información para
comprender algunas cuestiones pero que
básicamente tenemos los mismos derechos
y las mismas responsabilidades que
cualquier persona andrés habla más
reciente dijiste este concepto no de
niños eternos crees que hay una suerte y
de infantilización de las personas con
discapacidad y que entonces esto digamos
refuerza más no la idea de que quizás
son personas asexuadas como suele
decirse en algunos sectores
y absolutamente hay una infantilización
pero que no sólo tiene que ver
y personas que desconocen por completo
a personas con discapacidad
lamentablemente también se ve en muchas
familias por ejemplo padres y madres que
tienen hijas con discapacidad y entonces
para esa familia esa hija con
discapacidad es una niña eterna no crece
hay muchísimas sobreprotección es decir
protección al límite de decir bueno de
negarme de negarles la posibilidad de
salir solas de elegir con quién salir
ocurre mucho esto
no en todos los casos no pero muchas
veces digo no sólo tiene que ver con los
prejuicios de personas que no tuvieron
contacto con mujeres con discapacidad
sino también el dentro al interior de
las propias familias sin esto haber
digamos red y no la red de la que formas
parte todo esto que nos está contando
llevó a que red y lanzara la campaña
nosotras también gozamos no hay una
fuerte necesidad de enviar un mensaje no
que ayuda a derribar todos estos
preconceptos de lo que venías hablando
verdad contanos de qué se trata esta
campaña cuál es el principal mensaje que
es necesario llevar a la mayor cantidad
de gente posible y por un lado bueno
está esta campaña surgió a raíz de unos
talleres que hicimos durante 2019 de
manera presencial y 2020 bueno de manera
virtual con mujeres con discapacidad de
distintos lugares del país bueno la
argentina es un país
extenso muy grande en extensión entonces
abarcamos cuatro regiones del país para
poder abarcar la mayor cantidad de
realidades posibles desde mujeres con
discapacidad de distintas edades
y de esos talleres la verdad es que
nosotras ya sospechábamos ya sabíamos
por qué haríamos todas nosotras también
somos mujeres con discapacidad pero
al encontrarnos con mujeres de distintas
regiones con distintas condiciones de
discapacidad
nos encontramos con una gran falta de
por un lado en algunos casos de acceso a
la información y por otro
de real ejercicio pleno de estos
derechos de los que hablábamos antes
entonces
por un lado las mismas mujeres que
participaron de los talleres decidieron
hacer una serie de spots radiales y
audiovisuales para dar a conocer cuáles
son sus derechos en primera persona y
cuáles son las barreras con las que se
encontraron por ejemplo en hospitales y
centros de salud
y también al interior de su familia como
decíamos antes eso por un lado y por el
otro a partir de todo esto de toda esta
experiencia tan enriquecedora de los
talleres lo que decidimos hacer fue
también una aplicación para celulares
con
con perspectiva de género y de
discapacidad entonces esta aplicación se
llama nuestra decisión lo que permite es
una aplicación de descarga gratuita lo
que permite es acceder por ejemplo a
e información sobre cuáles son los
derechos de las mujeres en particular de
las mujeres con discapacidad pero
también de las mujeres en general con
respecto a sus derechos sexuales y
reproductivos y esos derechos están
redactados en un lenguaje muy sencillo
pensando en mujeres con discapacidad
intelectual en mujeres con discapacidad
auditiva mujeres sordas para poder
acceder a esta información en un
lenguaje muy sencillo y además la
aplicación está pensada en un formato
accesible para mujeres con discapacidad
visual
y bueno la aplicación además tiene botón
nes para acceder a las líneas
telefónicas de
de ayuda por motivos de violencia de
género de violencia hacia las mujeres y
a la línea gratuita de el ministerio de
salud de la nación con informa que es
una línea que brinda información sobre
salud sexual y reproductiva estábamos
viendo mientras hablaban de las imágenes
precisamente de esta aplicación tan
importante no es innovadora ahora
quisiera hacerte otra pregunta no crees
que todos estos preconceptos a lo que
hacían referencia podrían quizás estar
vinculados a esta idea que vincula al
sexo con la procreación y la creencia el
prejuicio o mejor dicho no de que
personas con discapacidad tendrán
seguramente hijos con discapacidades
también hay algo de eso sí claro hay
algo de eso y de hecho una de las cosas
que estamos impulsando también nosotras
es una reforma a la ley de
esterilización quirúrgica que hay en la
argentina es decir la ley
por la cual a las mujeres se les pueden
llegar las trompas de falopio
porque lo que pedimos es que en el caso
de las mujeres con discapacidad
se exija al igual que todas las mujeres
y firma del consentimiento informado
para hacer esa práctica porque porque
lamentablemente todavía hay muchos casos
de niñas y mujeres con discapacidad a
quienes se les han ligado las trompas se
las ha esterilizado sin su
consentimiento muchas veces por pedido
de su familia justamente por esta
presunción sólo por el temor de que
nazca otro hijo u otra hija con
discapacidad sino por la presunción
errónea obviamente de que una mujer con
discapacidad no va a poder criar
pero también yo creo que hay otra cosa
hablábamos antes de este concepto de
niñas eternas
creo que además hay otra cosa por un
lado está este miedo pero también hay
otro temor descender
por un lado que las mujeres tres con
discapacidad
puedan
que el hecho de que se presume que la
mujer con discapacidad no va a tratar de
la sexualidad porque al ser una niña
y hay como un miedo de que el hecho de
que la mujer con discapacidad tenga sexo
sería equivalente a un abuso agua a algo
no buscado no deseado por esa mujer creo
que también hay un preconcepto con
respecto a eso y además está el
prejuicio contra contrapuesto el de que
la mujer con discapacidad puede llegar a
tener una sexualidad descontrolada y en
realidad no y ni una cosa ni la otra y
justamente lo que buscamos nosotros es
que las mujeres con discapacidad tengan
información
porque justamente como no es ni una cosa
ni la otra
lo que necesitamos es que esas mujeres
no carguen con s
prejuicio y que puedan entender que
tienen los mismos derechos que todas las
mujeres absolutamente andreas gracias
muchísimas gracias por tu presencia en
la entrevista de france 24 ha sido
realmente un placer dialogar contigo
vamos muchísimas gracias santiago a
disposición para cuando necesiten y
muchísimas gracias por el espacio un
gusto no reitero muchas gracias a ti ya
nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a continuar informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y en
france24 punto com
y